i'm ainsley earhart i'm brett baer i'm
katie pavlich and this is the fox news
rundown
[Music]
wednesday march 9th 2022
i'm dave anthony can all these sanctions
on russia stop vladimir putin in ukraine
putin is not going to give up if
anything uh my intelligence assessment
is he is going to escalate even further
i'm lisa brady the u.s is banning oil
and gas from russia but will that hurt
americans more than president putin
wherever you find a sanction if you find
a clever crook which is what the chinese
and the russians really are
they'll find a way around them
and i'm jimmy fella i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
we're now two weeks into russia's
invasion of ukraine putin seems
determined to continue on his murderous
path no matter the cost but president
biden says the u.s and nato is united
against it we're going to continue to
support the brave ukrainian people as
they fight for their country and the
president predicts ukraine will never be
a victory for putin
putin may be able to take a city
but he'll never be able to hold the
country but russia's leader sees it
differently the special military
operation is
going according to the plan vladimir
putin said the other day they're
fighting against nato expansion and
aggression and as for the economic
punishment the u.s and our allies have
imposed
these sanctions that are being imposed
they are akin to declaring war a former
defense intelligence agency officer an
american who grew up in the soviet union
says sanctions won't end the war yes
there will be an impact don't get me
wrong
but it will not change putin's behavior
rebecca coughler published a book last
summer putin's playbook russia's secret
plan to defeat america here are the top
three things that putin has done in
order to sanction proof his economy
number one putin has been pursuing a
de-dolarization strategy in favor of the
chinese yuan the european and the euro
and gold
number two he has beefed up his foreign
currency reserves they're right now at
an all-time high one of the highest in
the world number three putin has been uh
pursuing an import substitution strategy
whereby he directed his domestic
producers to produce indigenously
certain goods and services and putin has
been redirecting exports to china
so the decision calculus
has economic concerns and impact already
baked in by putin because he expected
this okay but the value of the ruble
went down there are
all these stories about thousands of
russian protesters who've been arrested
and all this and there was this thought
that the economics in russia was
collapsing that businesses couldn't do
business with america or or foreign
companies anymore and there was a
collapse going on there is that not
happening
all true there's definitely an economic
downturn
the russians have already uh suffered
economically during the
socialist period of the ussr so they're
quite used to uh shortages this was
simply the way of life as you mentioned
i'm originally from the former soviet
union so
whatever economic impact we will have on
russia with sanctions
they have survived much much more during
all of the uh wonderful glorious soviet
socialist system
the culture is very much focused on
suffering
unlike
american culture
is focused on fun freedom you know the
russian culture is all about suffering
and in fact this is one of the things
that putin factored in in his decision
calculus he believes that the russians
can out suffer
the adversary i.e
the americans and the europeans whom
they perceive as adversary number one
you
in the soviet union as a child as you
grew up you didn't have social media
now they do have that i know that even
alexey navalny who's a prisoner in
russia is putting out information on
social media from his cell
are people like him able to turn
russians against vladimir putin
navalny is a very very brave man uh look
who was the target of a brutal attack
on him by the russian intelligence
services whereby he was poisoned with a
military-grade nerve agent and yes he
continues to spread the word to
galvanize the russian people against
putin
my assessment
dave is that at this stage
it would be very very difficult to turn
you know the russians ultimately in
masses right in the in in such a to such
a level that it would actually produce
the level of backlash
uh that would end up in the removal of
president putin why because the guy is
brutal and so people around him are
really afraid okay and again also the
oligarchs they don't bite the hand that
feeds them so my confidence level is
very low that a coup or regime change
could be produced from the inside
civilian casualties abhorrent here in
the us we've tried to avoid those in our
conflicts in iraq and afghanistan
obviously in ukraine russia has been
targeting civilians killing civilians
hitting apartment buildings and all of
that
that is not something that the russians
feel the same way as americans when it
comes to war right
that is absolutely correct the russians
have a much higher tolerance for
casualties
they conduct what we call punitive
military operations whereby civilians
are targeted with the idea that the
level of suffering will be incurred to
such an extent that it would compel
president zelinski in this case to
either flee or voluntarily surrender
so that the suffering is stopped and
this is an atrocious uh strategy but
this is how the russians are they fight
dirty in order to achieve what they have
decided to achieve
supposedly russian soldiers are said to
be demoralized in ukraine some of them
didn't even know they were going in to
do this they may not support what's
going on there is also talk that
vladimir putin underestimated the will
of the ukrainian people to fight back
that now putin feels cornered do you
believe those things
i do yes um
so these people are related and it is
really
atrocious that right now they've been
pitted against each other and russian
soldiers do not want to kill ukrainian
you know at the at the lower level and
this is why putin has requested
um
syrian
foreign fighters and kadir the uh the
chechen fighters because they don't have
the the same level of um
relations so that they can even brutally
you know deal with uh ukrainian uh
civilian casualties and that's
absolutely horrible
he absolutely uh
did underestimate uh dave ukrainians
have put up an amazing will to fight
president zielinski has displayed the
type of leadership that the davos crowd
and the experts quote unquote in
brussels and washington can learn a
thing or two from
it it is you know it is a tragedy the
ukrainians are fighters but in the end
unfortunately
it's not going to make a difference just
simply because in mathematical terms
right in military terms the russian
military just trumps hands down
ukrainian military which has improved
but it still is absolutely over matched
by the russians
putin's not going to give up is he he's
not going to give in he's not going to
give
zielinski a victory in peace talks or
anything like that do you believe he's
going to go until he takes ukraine
putin is not going to give up if
anything uh my intelligence assessment
is he is going to escalate even further
you just mentioned a
corner right putin once cornered he's
gonna fight even harder unleash a
backlash including possibly cyber
attacks and space warfare attacks
including on our soil and this is why we
had dhs issuing alerts for our
businesses and individuals to really
brace for potentially for a russian
cyber attacks
beyond that since your book is this
russia's secret plan to defeat america
you have written that
way only
a weapon of armageddon can defeat the
u.s and
the president of russia did put his
nuclear forces on high alert early on in
this invasion they've done test runs
near the u.s do you believe he would
actually strike america with a nuclear
weapon
i do but only in certain conditions uh
dave it's important to understand that
the threshold for putin unleashing an
armageddon nuclear warfare type of
strike is high okay
uh the only in the conditions that putin
believes he is losing
a and b
the united states and nato are about to
intervene in the conflict of ukraine to
fight on the ukrainian side
that he would contemplate such a thing
okay because if if putin is afraid of
anything he's afraid of the fury
of nato forces led by the united states
because he has seen how we fight in
afghanistan iraq
syria libya so he knows that if we were
to intervene he would lose and this is
why on police orders a top secret plan
was developed
that includes what we call a preemptive
strike including a cyber warfare strike
space warfare and even nuclear
a low yield nuclear weapon and wouldn't
be done on the united states it would be
done in europe president biden
understands this and this is why he's
against the no-fly zone and
i very rarely agree with president joe
biden but in this case i agree a no-fly
zone will be interpreted by the russians
as an act of war and it might
very well trigger a preemptive doctrine
and this is why biden is not authorizing
it
why did you leave the soviet union what
drove you to come to america
i was raised uh by my mom dave uh to
always go to america
since i was a little girl she wanted me
to learn english she just and i don't
know how she came up with this idea but
my family was anti-communist they didn't
agree with the soviet system which is
actually horrible and
i came and went through the immigration
process and now i'm just so proud to be
americans uh that is why i went to the
intelligence community um in the
aftermath of september 11th terrorist
attacks because i wanted to serve and
give back to my adopted homeland by
alerting you know our national security
apparatus about putin's plan
unfortunately um i wasn't listened to
and this is why i had to uh write a book
yeah he wrote he will more likely than
not surprise the west with another
hostile act like crimea within two years
well it did happen indeed the book is
putin's playbook russia's secret plan to
defeat america rebecca koffler former
defense intelligence agency officer
thank you very much for joining us
thank you very much dave pleasure to be
here with you and your audience
[Music]
this is jimmy fallon with your fox news
commentary coming up
day 14 of war in ukraine the assault
ordered by russian president vladimir
putin leaving a growing scar of death
and destruction and turning more than
two million ukrainians into refugees so
far as soldiers and civilians fight to
defend their country
please increase the pressure of
sanctions
against this
country and police recognize this
country as a terrorist state ukrainian
president velodemir zelinski threw a
translator addressing the british
parliament on tuesday more sanctions are
happening we're banning all imports of
russian oil and gas and energy
that means russian oil will no longer be
acceptable at u.s ports and the american
people will
deal another powerful blow to putin's
war machine president biden says we
won't be part of subsidizing putin's war
a step many in congress support but
while announcing the ban he reiterated a
warning about costs here at home putin's
war is already hurting american families
at the gas pump gas prices hitting a new
record 4 17 a gallon in the aaa average
for regular unleaded the president says
they'll likely rise more so is it worth
it and will it affect putin even if many
countries join in i think it's worth it
to try to
sanction russia any way you can to stop
this
horrible miscarriage of justice that's
going on in ukraine with the invasion
fox businesses david asman but there are
always ways that countries can get
around sanctions and one has to be aware
that the most vital
ally that russia has right now is china
and china
sops up oil like a sponge sops up water
and the oil that they're looking at
right now licking their lips is the oil
that russia has that it's got to get rid
of since we're not going to be buying
russian oil europe's not going to be
buying russian oil a lot of other
countries are not going to be buying
russian oil china's going to try to find
some way to bring it in and that's this
is all supposition on my part by the way
it hasn't started yet as far as i know
although there may be some trial runs
but it's clear that china is trying to
play all sides on this issue at one
point they were critical of the invasion
of ukraine at another point they said
they didn't favor sanctions against
russia so they're trying to play both
sides but clearly
they need the oil that russia is now
going to have and russia's going to find
some way to get it to them so in the end
even though it's good to sanction russia
and
it makes the world feel better about
doing something against their invasion
of ukraine wherever you find a sanction
if you find a clever crook which is what
the chinese and the russians really are
they'll find a way around them
in the meantime
the oil prices that have been rising are
a big driver of overall inflation right
so one of the things the president
acknowledged was
look this is
going to continue to hurt here at home
but he didn't acknowledge that what this
administration is saying is that the
rise in oil prices and gas prices at the
pump are all because of russia's
invasion of ukraine not true you go back
to the day after president biden was
elected what happened is you saw the
price of gasoline and oil but
particularly gasoline prices go up in
preparation for joe biden's war on
fossil fuels on monday of this week jen
saki came out and chastised fox news's
peter ducey uh for suggesting that there
is that the the rise in prices have
something to do with the blind
administration's war on fossil fuels in
fact she said facts can be inconvenient
peter we have actually produced more oil
it is at record levels that is simply
not true in december of 2019 we produced
12 million 900 000 barrels per day of
oil december 2019
in december 2021 we were producing 11
million 500 000 barrels per day so we
are not only not at record levels we are
producing so much less
oil than we were during the last year of
the trump administration if we ramped up
to that level we could more than make up
for the oil that we are missing from
russia right now so uh one oil prices
were rising long before russia invaded
ukraine and two we have oil production
way down from where it was uh in the
last year of the trump administration
now part of that has to do with the
pandemic absolutely true but gas prices
began going up throughout the period
right before the pandemic and all during
the pandemic gas prices at the pump
stayed below two dollars and fifty cents
for a gallon of gasoline now if you go
in you can clearly see it's four to five
dollars on the east coast if you're in
california it's up to seven bucks a
gallon because of biden's war on fossil
fuels not because of russia's invasion
of ukraine although that supercharged
the situation that certainly has made it
worse it's exacerbated the price rise
that began when biden was elected
president the president himself is
pushing back on the argument that he's
hurting u.s production it's simply not
true that my administration or policies
are holding back domestic energy
production
that's simply not true and spokeswoman
jensaki frequently points to drilling
permits already approved but unused so i
would suggest you ask the oil companies
why they're not using those if there's a
desire to drill more the american
petroleum institute issued its own
response tuesday noting that leases are
issued before exploration so not all
leased land has resources to tap into
they're urging the administration to
send a message that america is open for
energy investment well first of all you
have a lot of banks that have stopped
dealing with fossil fuel companies
because the banks want to lower their
carbon footprint i'm sure you've heard
about the the woke corporation and the
other thing to to mention that you hear
from the administration well we have 9
000 leases that we've given out to oil
companies and they haven't they haven't
uh drilled anything on those leases that
we've given them
last year you know how many leases there
were 40 000 so do the math i mean we
have a situation now where over 10 000
of those leases have been drilled on
over the past year so they are drilling
on on land that has been leased by the
federal government it's untrue to say
that there hasn't been a dramatic
increase in drilling in the past year
and a half since the pandemic really
began to settle down a little bit and
these facts by the way come out from
very very reliable sources the eia is
the official energy statistician for the
united states go and look it up and you
can see that all the statistics that
i've been mentioning are there and as
jen sackey said facts can be
inconvenient but they are most
inconvenient for the biden
administration
president biden remains under pressure
from his own party to keep the green
agenda moving new york democratic
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
called it alarming that people are
pushing to either increase production
or imports
including the possibility of buying more
oil from iran or venezuela
which could also have other
environmental impacts correct
the dirtiest oil producer that i know of
is venezuela the venezuelan oil company
is called petavesa that oil company has
done extraordinary environmental damage
over the years since the government took
it over there are a lot of non-engineers
that are involved not only in pump in
the oil but dealing with oil spills
between 2010
and 2016
pedesta has had more than 46 000 spills
of crude and other pollutants so if the
president cares at all about the
environment he would never even think
of using venezuelan oil it's just it's a
disgrace
everybody in fact every major
state-owned oil producer whether it's
the saudis all of the opec nations
venezuela russia they produce oil much
dirtier than we do so the point is is
that if he really cared about
ecological concerns he would not even be
thinking of asking the venezuelans or
asking the saudis or asking the russians
to produce more he would produce more
here in the united states
many democrats argue the current
situation with oil and gas the surging
prices just helps make the case we need
to be less dependent on oil in general i
mean playing devil's advocate here is
that true at least in general going
forward it would be great if we could if
if people come up with the uh an
invention of a better way to save energy
a better battery for energy if you will
or some way to convert
uh solar energy or wind energy into a
form of energy that you could transport
you know with our with our natural gas
we can liquefy that national uh natural
gas
and liquefied natural gas can be sent
abroad to those european nations that
are trying to break free from their
dependence on russian oil you can't do
that with solar you can't do that with
wind if you want to transport energy
it's very difficult to do so
over land uh not to mention by sea or or
other transport means so even even
transporting energy over land you you
lose a tremendous amount of that energy
in doing so so that there are a whole
myriad of problems with regard to energy
even elon musk the the founder and
controller of tesla has said that it
kills me to say this but you have to
produce more fossil fuel energy in this
country you we are not ready to make the
transition
one other thing for you there have been
polls showing many americans are willing
to pay more if it helps ukraine or
punishes vladimir putin
um
but could it backfire on the president
ultimately because this is in the
context of higher prices right now for a
lot of things
and
how does the fed weigh all this
information
that's a big question yes that's a very
big question but to the first part those
polls were taken before
people faced these dramatic raises in in
prices at the pump i suspect that as we
get closer to 10 a gallon gas and people
realize that they can't afford lunch
anymore because they have to fill up
their gas tank their their willingness
to sacrifice a bit for the sake of the
ukrainians is going to diminish
radically now with regard to the fed
it's a very interesting question we have
an inflation in this country obviously
it's not just gasoline although gasoline
is most important what happens when that
happens is the government sells debt to
the marketplace in order to pay their
bills they sell bonds and the federal
reserve buys those bonds and guess what
they use to pay for those bonds paper
money that they manufacture in order to
literally out of thin air they snap
their fingers and the treasury
prints money that we use to buy the
government debt and that causes
inflation and the fed realizes that
that's the main root cause of inflation
so they said they're going to raise
interest rates stop printing money in
order to buy the debt and raise interest
rates in order to pull back
some of that cash that's floating out
there causing inflation well it's that
that could cause a recession and with
all of the problems that we now have
with regard to russia uh and with regard
to bad economic policies in other areas
uh that they they are probably going to
be
more reluctant
less likely that is to actually stop
printing money than they have been so
uh fasten your seat belts folks it's
we're going to have a lot more inflation
before we have a lot less inflation and
right now the fed's in no position to to
stop it
fox business anchor david asman thank
you very much for your time my pleasure
thank you
from the fox news podcast network
download and listen to tyrus and tim
every week fox nation host tyrus and fox
news contributor kat tim give their hot
takes explore weird headlines and share
amusing stories subscribe and listen now
by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
jimmy fallon
what's on your mind so the nfl suspended
atlanta falcons wide receiver calvin
ridley for all the next season because
he gambled on football but for my money
this is a losing bet one the nfl
advertises gambling during every single
second of every game and two they
advertise gambling during every single
second of every pre-game and post game
like if you're gonna suspend guys for
doing what you sell in commercials you
might as well ban them for eating
buffalo wings and chugging beers which
i'm pretty sure the new york jets do
before every game judging by the way
they play the nfl says they can't have
players associated with gambling because
it's concerned about the perception the
games might be compromised but upon
further review that play does not stand
as called because they've got dozens of
broadcasters ex-players ex-coaches
league executives and celebrities
touting gambling picks before every game
the point is like beer buffalo wings
pizza and pickup trucks gambling is part
of the nfl's image now for better or
worse they can try to convince people
otherwise but the odds ain't good i'm
jimmy fallon
you have been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to fox news radio's hourly newscast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news visit foxnews.com
[Music]
living the brain is a podcast hosted by
fox news channel's shannon breen sharing
inspirational stories personal anecdotes
and an insider's perspective on actions
and rulings from the high court find it
now on apple podcasts google play and
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes